we are into the final hour of our live
coverage of the scouting combine 2020
indianapolis indiana joining us now it's
edge rusher defensive tackle linebacker
day alabama edge rusher terrell lewis
how are you i'm good man can't complain
you got perfect timing you walked up you
sat down and boom we're back on the air
you got to have you have timing like
that all week you'll be the first
overall pick i hope so dude
how's it going so far it's going well
it's a beautiful experience to be out
here and kind of just cherish all this
any part of it irritate you or just make
you think i just can't wait for this to
be over no i wouldn't say so even
because going to the senior bowl it kind
of prepared you for all this stuff it's
kind of basically like to me i think
like the senior bowl on steroids like
it's just more chaos a lot of
a lot more hype to it and stuff like
that everybody's here so just a bigger
atmosphere what was the biggest thing
you learned about the game about what's
coming from your time at the senior bowl
um just learning how to carry yourself
and conduct yourself as a professional
in all types of atmospheres and you know
saying showing always showing the best
version of yourself
you've probably already gotten a lot of
that practice though playing for nick
saban right i mean basically the most
intense coach that the nfl could offer
other than bill belichick what's the
biggest lesson you've learned from your
time with him um basically kind of along
the lines of the same thing and then
also basically you know learning how to
manage your time
um focus on not only being just a
football player but also
you know as far as
going along with the media being
professional with how you do things time
management as far as being the places on
time and then
as far as the game-wise you learn so
much about football isn't it i could
talk about football all day so
we've had some alabama guys on who say
that nick saban is actually funny in my
reaction it is funny how how in the
world is that guy funny what's funny
about him what's funny about nick saban
uh it's fun he's funny in ways where
it's like
he may think it's funny and it may not
be funny but because he thinks it's like
a dad's joke yeah it's like a man you
laugh because he he really thinks this
is funny so sometimes it'll be funny
like that but then he also cracks jokes
with like all right that was a good one
you know he's in his mid 60s now but
he's still got that ability
to scare you what's worse getting a look
from him or having him yell at you
um i think it it's a mixture of both
i've never really had coach saban like
chew me out but at the same time i've
seen him where he kind of gives you that
look like
you're lucky i don't feel like you're
saying yelling right now or something
like that so it definitely he
he has that intimidating factor
especially as a young guy as a freshman
when guys come in they're like man he
kind of you're saying you can tell he's
hard on the freshman but he's really
just trying to establish you know seeing
his superior like basically him being
you know saying your coach and wants you
to know that he wants the best for you
want you to be your best who's the best
opponent you faced at the college level
who outside of bama
yes
um i'll probably say isaiah win from
georgia and that's the national
championship yeah what what made him
that good that day because he was he he
wasn't a tackle that was afraid of
physicality and then also as a youngster
as a past
he would say against the past he was he
had very good feet and quick on his feet
agile could change direction and stuff
like that are you more of a power guy or
more of a moves and get around the edge
and out finesse the tackle guy uh i feel
like i'm more so balanced like i like to
work speed to power but at the same time
i can beat you with speed i think that's
what sets up your speed to power if you
can beat a guy with speed around the
edge then that's what makes people
susceptible to be getting beat by they
don't know what's coming that's the kid
you don't want to know what's coming you
got to say move all the time they know
what to do you want to be able to mix it
up and catch them off guard
because i i know when i was younger i
used to be just a speed rush and i'm
like i can't just keep doing this
because then once they get their hands
on me it's like okay i'm dead what did
you do to develop the other aspect of
your game once you realized you couldn't
just be a speed rusher i had to fall in
love with the weight room
how hard of a courtship was that um with
my trainer it wasn't really that hard it
was more so about being able being able
to put the weight on to keep saying
the weight on because i had high
metabolism so i could work out but then
at the same time
i won't be that strong because i'm not
eating enough to
keep up all those calories and stuff
like that so it definitely helped with
him you know helping me
not only focus on the weight room but
also focus on my eating that helped me
gain weight and put that strength on in
the right places where did strength come
from upper body lower body both
especially coming out of high school
both yeah
um
you you mentioned earlier when i asked
you who's the best opponent you've seen
you said other than alabama which made
me think the best players you've seen
are on alabama who's the best teammate
that you've seen in alabama
give me the best one
number one the guy that stands out this
is the guy
out of my whole career yeah
um
well i'll say
because there's so many to choose from
but
right now
a person that always has the impression
on me and probably the young cat jalen
water really yeah he's a dog yeah what
what makes his game so good he just he
got that dog mentality as a receiver and
you saying he's one of those guys where
if i get the ball you never know what
may happen i might score
and then you just you get a game changer
yeah
um what do you think of tua
he's a dog but he's a humble dog
he
a competitor like to compete and then
he's just a great teammate great leader
great person
how old were you when you realized that
you had the skills to make it in
football at a really high level up to
and including the nfl
um i feel like i always knew but then i
never i'm saying
i didn't see it all the way through
until probably about
my junior year of high school so
probably about like 6 15 16 16.
um
at the college level what was the
hardest part of the adjustment because
we've seen highlights of guys at high
school and you guys are all done the
guys who make it here were dominant in
high school you hit a little bit of a
ceiling at the college level how hard
was it for you to make that adjustment
and to get to the point where you were
as dominant in college as you were in
high school
i think it all
it came it was the transition was really
tough early on just trying to transition
to the the speed part of the game as far
as how fast it is the terminology and
stuff like that especially going to a
school like bama where they if we were
on a really complex defense really nfl
style defense so it's like you got to
learn it to be able to play fast and
make the adjustments i'm saying based
off any motion and stuff like that so
once i kind of got a hold of that and
learning the game as far as x's and
nodes and terminology and how to adjust
the things
then it just became a factor of okay now
that i'm playing fast just get
comfortable to playing against the level
of competition i'm playing against well
excellent preparation at alabama for the
next level terrell lewis we wish you all
the best enjoy the week here in indy and
we'll see how things shake out in late
april with the draft thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports